[Music]
jeremiah is in atlanta hi jeremiah
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
uh got a question right now um
so been listening to you i guess for
about a year now started the baby steps
and i'm
probably i think right now i'm about
six grand away from only having my
mortgage
left to pay um but besides that i had um
next year i'm set to be at about
55 for my salary um
a friend of mine who has done very well
for himself and owns his own business
has offered me
a job that could potentially double my
income um if it was a family member i
pretty sure i would have no issues
saying you know i appreciate it no
thanks because
i don't want you know i really don't
want to work with family so that would
you know kind of have any sort of
animosity if anything went south
but with it being you know not a family
it's
somebody i've known for about 15 or 20
years is it a
smart choice or do i leave it where i'm
at what does potentially
make double the income mean uh
so well in passive we were talking and
he you know
he said hey you know you know quit quit
what you're doing now just come work for
me he's i got a six figure job for you
that's how that's how serious the
conversation's been
for that that's about it so i mean i
know so let's get something straight
down and yeah let's get something
straight this does not work
if he's giving you a job paying you six
figures and you don't know how to do a
six-figure job
that's called your friend giving you
money for free and that's not going to
work right
okay so what i've got to understand if
i'm you
step one is to figure out okay i'm going
to be doing something
that is worth six figures to his
company and that he would pay someone
else six figures to do the same job
and i'm able to do that job
okay so um if he's asking you to do
something you can't
do then you're going to disappoint this
is going to blow up
if he's uh if he wouldn't pay someone
else six figures to do the job then this
is going to blow up
because it's charity it's not a job or
if you hate it if he's
bringing you on to be a salesman and you
hate sales
eventually you're gonna have to
disappoint him right yeah
right you know so i'm not good at it i
hate it or he's not gonna pay someone
else that so i gotta understand what
those details are right now it sounds
like a very very
off-the-cuff comment not a job offer
is that fair yeah okay so let's let's go
back
you know to him and say okay were you
serious
what would i be doing and why would i be
worth that okay
now let's take it a step further then
and give you some guidelines of how this
works
when uh mentally healthy people
emotionally healthy people spiritually
healthy people work together
they can be family they can be friends
some of my best friends on the
planet work on my team here
and i'm per then they were friends
before some of them
some of them were friends became friends
while they were working here i've just
got unbelievable respect for them i love
them
they're just good people they're great
at their jobs
everything's good okay now how can you
do that how can you work with family
which you said you wouldn't do
or or something near the family which is
a 15 year old friend
the way you do that is this thing called
just mutual
respect and clear roles when you work
for him
uh he's the ceo and you're the whatever
it is your title is
uh you're not friends in the sense of he
doesn't owe you something because your
friendship
he owes you fairness and dignity
clarity uh guidance
support that's what a leader owes anyone
that works on their team if they're a
quality leader
and you owe him that you're game on
you're not
mailing it in you're not backstabbing
him you're not
half butting it as an employee uh
because
you know anywhere else you worked you
get fired for doing that
and if your friend fires you for doing
that then he did that because he was
your friend
not because he's a mean old boss because
you're a half
employee so if you go and you do your
part at work and he
does his part at work and that is and
when you're at work you wear the hat
of he wears the hat of boss and you wear
the hat of team member
then when you take those hats off and
later on you're hanging out
uh and you got two hats on that say
friends then you could treat each other
differently there but you don't get
a pass at ramsey because your last
name's ramsay
as a matter of fact you kind of got to
bring it more
and you don't get a pass at ramsey
because i've known you 40 years
because i've got friends that i've 40
years i've known them
and they're on this team and i've been
on this team 15 or 20 years
of the 40 years i've known them but they
still don't get a pass by the way i
don't get a pass either i don't get to
be a jerk to them
just because we we've been friends for
years so they have to take extra crap
off of me as the boss does that make
sense
yes sir so treat people the right way
as the leader as the employee and then
you don't have to worry about whether
you're friends or not
and you can still be friends right a
good friend would sit down and tell you
if you were half button it right
so how real is this fly by job offer
oh it's i mean it's it's pretty
pretty real i'm pretty sure i can head
over there to the house and talk to him
about it today
yeah i would do that i think you need
some relational clarity
and you need some clarity for your soul
because you're on a on a
on a financial trajectory you're working
hard and the lure of
another 50 grand feels really good get
some clarity on that
feels great yeah get some clarity on
that well it could be that you're
underpaid where you are
and you built your value up in the
market and that you know you could land
this
type of a position somewhere else as
well that's possible and it could be
that he's going to say
yeah all you got to do is move 48 cars a
month and you can make a hundred
thousand dollars and you could say yeah
i'm
i'm out yeah i don't think i don't think
i can do that or i want to do that
yeah so uh number one find out and
firm up that you're gonna bring value
that's equal that number two you're
gonna like the type of position
and then the last part is that whole
last diatribe i just did was
you can work with friends you can be
friends you know
one guy said you could never be friends
with people that you lead of course you
should be friends with people you lead
that's stupid if you're a good leader
you should you should love people enough
when you're leading them to be friends
with them
but that does not mean that i can't hold
you accountable it doesn't even mean i
can't fire you
it means i will fire you i fired some of
my best friends
for different reasons i had some of my
best friends quit you know and
we remain friends in most cases
depending on what
is going on there but uh but it's not
that that
you know friends can't work together
that's not true mentally
healthy and balanced friends can i think
that is more of a
of an indictment of what friendship has
come to mean
which means i'm just gonna entitlement
i'm just gonna make you feel good and
say you go
you go dave and i'm gonna be you man
they're gonna tell you something hard
i'm never gonna hold you accountable i'm
never gonna
demand excellence out of you yeah
friendship does all those things
even if you're not on my friendship does
that's right i guarantee you man i got
men in my life that hold me to that and
i hold them to that heck yeah and
they don't they're not on my payroll
yeah yeah that's but that's real
friendship that's exactly right
tough love no honey it's love just love
man yeah